and he took me to this shop where I met
the shaven headed fearsome bloke behind
the counter and I'd seen the parcel I'd
seen it was about 25 or 30 kilos of
cannabis or something like that and by
now there was Mr balded bloke and about
three or four of his mates stood either
side of me in this shop and I was
refusing to have the money obviously the
flash money that I'd booked out in New
Scotland Yard was refusing to have that
cash taken into the
shop and he was getting the raving up
about this in fact at one point he said
if you do not bring that money in here
the only way you will get out of here is
with six of those in your back and he
pointed at the swords and the knives and
all of that that were on the
wall and I was convinced that he meant
what he said